y
[Música]
super domingo electoral en américa del
sur
andrés zarautz y guillermo lasso se
disputan la segunda vuelta presidencial
en un ecuador polarizado mientras 18
candidatos intentan convencer a los
escépticos peruanos para pasar a la
segunda vuelta presidencial entretanto
cuatro departamentos de bolivia elegirán
gobernadores en el ballottage
brasil supera los 350.000 fallecidos por
la pandemia y el presidente ya ir por el
sónar o continúa en contra de las
restricciones e incluso las comparó con
una dictadura refiriéndose a venezuela
país que pagó más del 50 por ciento del
plan kóvacs para acceder a las vacunas
contra kobe 19
más de 15.000 personas han sido
evacuadas en san vicente y las
granadinas debido a la segunda erupción
del volcán la sufría que expulsó ceniza
y enorme columna de humo los expertos
advierten que la constante actividad
podría provocar más erupciones por lo
que se prevén nuevas evacuaciones
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 su reo blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarle feliz domingo
comenzamos en la región andina de
américa latina- perú y ecuador viven hoy
domingo 11 de abril sus elecciones
presidenciales los preparativos en ambos
países se desarrollaron entre fuertes
medidas de seguridad para distribuir el
material electoral en todo el país la
preocupación para que el proceso
electoral sea transparente es cada vez
mayor en los dos estados para evitar
denuncias de fraude además también se
prepararon los protocolos para evitar
contagios de ccoo y 19 en pleno repunte
de casos más romeros a la nos cuenta más
millones de papeletas se distribuyeron
el sábado en ecuador para que los
votantes puedan acudir a las urnas del
domingo y elegir presidente en segunda
vuelta entre andrés araud y guillermo
lasso la primera vuelta estuvo manchada
por denuncias de fraude del movimiento
indígena la estrecha vigilancia del
proceso electoral por parte de las
autoridades y el ejército trata de
evitar que las denuncias se repitan todo
nuestro contingente todos nuestros
los empleados están listos los miembros
de junta receptora del voto han sido
capacitados nuevamente se les están
entregando en cada paquete electoral va
a un flujograma de las actividades que
tienen que cumplir para reforzar lo de
la primera vuelta en perú el material
electoral también se distribuyó a todos
los puntos de votación para acoger a los
más de 25 millones de ciudadanos
llamados a votar en las presidenciales
están saliendo de este espacio 200
camiones acompañados también de 200
patrulleros
[Música]
estamos movilizando 450 toneladas
incluye material electoral y material
también vinculado a la protección y la
seguridad de los miembros de mesa frente
al vino en la primera vuelta en perú se
da por descontado que ninguno de los 18
candidatos superará el 50 por ciento de
los votos necesarios para acceder a la
presidencia directamente el país se
encuentra inmerso en un fuerte repunte
de contagios de kobe 19 por ejemplo el
periodo de votación se extendió a 12
horas para evitar aglomeraciones con
estas elecciones pero trata de resolver
la crisis política que lo ha llevado a
tener cuatro presidentes en cinco años
hablemos ahora de bolivia el país vivirá
la segunda ronda de los comicios para
elegir a los gobernadores de cuatro de
los nueve departamentos que conforman el
país la paz chuquisaca pando y tarija
el gobernante de movimiento al
socialismo más busca imponerse tras la
consolidación de la votación que alcanzó
en la primera ronda está previsto que
los resultados sean entregados en un
plazo máximo de una semana según declaró
el presidente del tribunal supremo
electoral aunque el organismo espera
entregarlos mucho antes
y seguimos en nuestro continente para
hablar de brasil país que registró dos
mil 616 muertes en el último día con lo
que ya suman 300 51 mil 334 víctimas
mortales desde que fuera notificado en
marzo del año pasado el primer
fallecimiento en el país por cuenta de
el coronavirus pese a las cifras algunas
regiones del país como río de janeiro
flexibilizaron las medidas restrictivas
tras 10 días de cierre varios
restaurantes comercios y sitios
turísticos volvieron a abrir sus puertas
al público por su parte el presidente ya
ir bolsonaro dijo que el país está
viviendo una dictadura y comparó las
restricciones por el virus con las que
denominó como libertades negadas en
venezuela'
y es que venezuela dice que ha asegurado
el pago de la mitad de las vacunas que
debe recibir del mecanismo kóvacs son
11.3 millones de dosis el país ha
recibido 750 mil soluciones de las
vacunas rusa y china para un total de 30
millones de habitantes menos que la
mayoría de los países de la región el
tema divide nuevamente a la posición del
gobierno
los líderes y la oposición de venezuela
están divididos sobre la mayoría de
temas y la vacunación del cobi 19 no es
una excepción la vicepresidenta de
venezuela del xiv rodríguez informó que
el gobierno pagó la mitad del precio
para la adquisición de más de 10
millones de dosis a través del mecanismo
kóvacs yakovac recibió el equivalente a
50 y 3.8 millones de euros a lo que la
oposición respondió que esto prueba que
el gobierno mintió cuando dijo que no
podía pagar estas dosis antes debido a
las sanciones dicen ahora recientemente
que no que es que está bloqueado recurso
o comprarlas bien viene de dosis
lista minutos los recursos según datos
oficiales más de 170 mil venezolanos se
han contagiado de kobe 19 más de 1.700
han muerto pero el número de casos
podría ser mucho mayor
la gente está haciendo fila para obtener
oxígeno para los enfermos
si tan sólo pueden tener a mucha gente
pero a mí en chino no me siguen adam en
recursos de medicina
necesitamos necesitamos a toda esta
gente
los venezolanos han enfrentado escasez
de medicamentos y otros productos
básicos como alimentos durante años la
oposición culpa nicolás maduro de la
crisis el presidente dice que los
problemas se deben a las sanciones de
eeuu una escasez que ha empeorado con la
pandemia
la isla caribeña de san vicente y las
granadinas se ha cubierto de ceniza tras
la erupción explosiva del volcán la
sufría la erupción del viernes en la
primera de esta magnitud desde 1979 deja
hasta el momento una persona fallecida y
más de 15 mil evacuados veamos
mira lo realmente entró en erupción dios
mío los habitantes de la isla caribeña
de san vicente que no siguieron las
indicaciones iniciales de evacuar
acabaron huyendo de la erupción
despavoridos
estamos ya nos estamos llenos no puedo
más tengo que moverme tengo que correr
las imágenes apenas se alcanzan a captar
la enorme columna de ceniza el volcán
llamado su fiel entró en erupción el
viernes por primera vez en 40 años ahora
gran parte de san vicente está cubierta
por el polvo y el aire o el azufre estas
personas fueron evacuadas en barco a
otras islas cercanas mientras que otras
miles se refugiaron en albergues
proporcionados por el gobierno un
coordinador local intenta tranquilizar a
la gente
y todo va según lo planeado esto es lo
que el gobierno ha estado poniendo en
práctica no es un simulacro en total más
de 15.000 residentes han tenido que oír
los científicos dicen que la sofiex
podría seguir expulsando sustancias
durante varios días más o incluso
semanas
la organización de energía atómica iraní
informó sobre un incidente en la
instalación ante enriquecimiento de
uranio en natanz
el fallo se registró en la red de
distribución eléctrica de la planta se
trata del mismo sitio donde este sábado
se inauguraron nuevas centrifugadoras
prohibidas en el acuerdo nuclear de 2015
según teherán el hecho no provocó
heridos ni contaminación y dijo que
investigan las causas de este incidente
el secretario de defensa de eeuu lloyd
austin llegó a israel en la primera
visita de un alto representante de la
administración byd en cuya postura sobre
irán ha preocupado al gobierno del
primer ministro benjamin netanyahu
sostiene fue recibido en el aeropuerto
de ben gurión de israel y más tarde
llegó al ministerio de defensa de la
ciudad de tel aviv donde fue recibido
por el ministro de esa cartera beny
gantz en la guardia de honor está
previsto que austin se reúna con
netanyahu durante la visita de dos hijas
[Música]
reino unido dentro en su tercer día de
duelo nacional tras la muerte del esposo
de la reina isabel segunda el príncipe
felipe duque de edimburgo un servicio
especial de recuerdo se llevará a cabo
en la catedral de canterbury en horas de
la tarde el periodo de duelo de una
semana culminará con el funeral del
duque el día sábado 17 de abril que se
llevará a cabo en la capilla de sant
george en el castillo de windsor no
habrá acceso al público ni procesión
pública previa su nieto el príncipe
harvey asistirá al funeral
de esta manera entonces llegamos al
final del informativo continúen con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias feliz domingo para todos feliz
mañana
[Música]
d
en un instante reportero
[Música]